the scale of this production you know
and it really is a big moving the vivid
colors of the sets the the scale of the
castle the music we built this
environment we built the village and
these incredible castle room they were
massive sets begs to be seen an iMac the
colors are so sumptuous the sound is
incredible Bill Condon has created this
old-fashioned musical in such a modern
way and it feels like it wants to jump
off the screen and the IMAX experience
be so tailor-made for a movie like this
it's like people's dream to be inside
that ballroom and inside that library
and in that small French Provincial
Village and I think to feel like you're
you're actually on those sets you're
inside those environments I think is
gonna blow people's mind show me the
girl
look at our what if she is the one the
one who break the spell hi max is more
beauty in the piece he's an the idea
that you can kind of open that up at the
top of the bottom was overwhelmed when
we started to see what it was looking
like in imax you know it just felt like
it was like being back on those sets you
know it really really came to life for
me with the CGI and just what they've
done with how far technology isn't it
has advanced to then marry that to this
already iconic story
I think everybody's going to feel like
they are completely in that film I mean
I feel like everybody's gonna feel like
they've just left out of their seats
into it I mean and to see it on a big
screen is the only way to do it I can't
wait to see you know it's gonna be
insane
you